I think the obstacles are the same as
the opportunities.
It's the way we like to look at them.
We have this really powerful
technological infrastructure that can do
really tremendous things at the same
time.
It's never going to be as flexible as
we'd like it to be just by nature of,
of,
of web technology.
So,
you know,
we can deliver news across the globe in
a matter of seconds or minutes.
And that's pretty amazing and we can
create a really,
really fascinating tools for our users
to take advantage of.
Um,
at the same time,
you know,
those technologies don't allow us to,
um,
to,
you know,
tool retool a,
the appearance or the presentation of
every piece of content in exactly the
way that we would like.
There's,
there's a real inherent limitations to
the tools.
So,
um,
it's,
you know,
it's two sides of the same coin.
Sure.
We,
we often get reader feedback,
both positive and negative no matter
what we do.
Um,
you know,
let me think.
Um,
there are times when,
um,
things that are really obvious to us,
you know,
and we've really tried to design them in
such a way that we think will be obvious
to readers who and users who have only
casual familiarity with the site and
we'll get feedback that,
that says,
you know,
they have no idea that,
that,
uh,
um,
what we intended was actually the case.
Um,
and I'm trying to think of an example
off the top of my head right now.
Um,
you know,
we'll,
we'll occasionally add sort of
alternative views to the homepage,
new experimental presentations of our
top content features like times wire.
We had one called times extra.
We have a social networking layer called
um,
called times people.
Um,
and these are things that we spent a lot
of time trying to make as intuitive and
it's easy to use as possible.
Um,
and sometimes,
you know,
we,
we hit the mark and a lot of times
people will ask us,
you know,
what does this thing do that you have
here?
I have really no idea,
no understanding of it.
And it's just sort of blows us out of
the water that you know,
that they can be.
So,
um,
you know,
what we've designed can be so as
unintuitive as,
as the reader might be interpreting it
as.
So that's always a,
that's,
that's I think one of the hardest and
most and most illuminating parts of the
job is really,
really constantly reminding yourself
that what's obvious to you is not
obvious to the users.
Well,
I'll tell you about a big project that
we finished up late last year for we,
we have a,
um,
a luxury magazine that comes into with
the Sunday paper called t,
um,
and that covers,
men's fashion,
women's fashion design,
travel,
living that,
that sort of stuff.
Really high end luxury.
And we had a site that we launched in
2007,
I believe that,
um,
you know,
we felt pretty,
pretty good about it at the time,
but it quickly became apparent that it
was,
it was too expensive to produce and
wasn't really yielding the results that
we were looking for.
So we worked most of last year,
2009 really overhauling that sites.
Um,
and moving it away from what had been a
presentation that was really centered
around what appeared in print to a brand
new kind of user experience that really
emphasize what we saw,
how we saw users interacting with the
content.
So instead of showing all the
photography and the photo spreads and
the feature stories as the sole main
gateway to that site,
we've moved to a new kind of experience
where the content is,
I'm a bit more atomized,
you can sort of access it from many
different many different ways and we're
really emphasizing the blog and have
the,
uh,
the site as,
um,
the major access point because what we
saw was that users responded best to our
blog even though it was not the major,
the main access point that they
responded to its timeliness and its,
and the brevity of the content.
Um,
and so we completely reoriented the
sites around that.
And,
and that was something I really pushed
for 'em hard in,
uh,
in late 2008,
early 2009.
And we were able to launch it late last
year.